90 minutes filming your videos setting
up your space testing your shot actually
hitting record that might have shocked
you there you might have thought an hour
and a half heather that's not enough
time i want to encourage you fry and
trim the fat you might need to be
practicing your script in the mirror two
nights before so that you sit down in
front of your camera and you're
delivering better content
so if you've decided that you want to go
all in on youtube this year i understand
that trying to fit youtube into your
current busy life whether that's running
a business running a household uh in
ministry whatever that looks like really
figuring out how do you make youtube
work in your life we're going to talk
about that and more in today's episode
of the think media podcast my name is
heather torres and i'm your host here on
the show and if you're brand new we want
to welcome you to what we're doing over
here on this podcast channel if you are
watching on youtube i want to encourage
you to subscribe here on this channel so
you get more in-depth uh conversations
around being a content creator growing
an online business around your youtube
channel and so much more and if you're
an audio listener i want to welcome you
and uh thank you for being a part of the
think media world as the time that i'm
recording this we are in the beginnings
of summer and if anyone's like me i've
already felt kind of the effects of
summer i want to be out by the pool i
want to not be filming videos um and i
really want to live that summer
lifestyle but i understand that figuring
out your calendar and being productive
with your time in this season right now
is what's going to catapult your success
in the future and so i'm going to be
breaking down first the five hour
youtube work week this is a proven
system of how you can spend 300 minutes
wisely uh in your life working on your
youtube channel we have people inside of
our think media community right now
inside our vra community who are using
this five hour youtube work week to help
them grow their youtube channel so i
want to share that with you and before
we jump into the featured content i want
to let you know about my free class
where i'm teaching you how to get to
your first 1000 subscribers on youtube
and in your first 1 000 and beyond and
this class i go into the three secrets
of success and what's holding a lot of
creators back from actually making your
best video so if you want to see that
free on-demand class you can do that
over at
tubemasterclass.com now before we get
into the walkthrough of the 300 minutes
you could be using wisely towards your
youtube channel i want to cover three
areas that i think are really critical
when it comes to talking about time
management in general or productivity as
the buzzword goes for uh how to be
structuring your time wisely now um i am
a homeschooling mom of three kiddos
right now we're on summer vacation which
is nice so i have a little bit more time
there um i'm helping to run think media
podcasts and running think media the
actual company itself so i know a thing
or two when it comes to having to juggle
your time and here's one misconception i
think that when people think that they
can multitask that that actually is a
superpower and i actually don't see it
as a superpower i want you to really be
focused in the different areas of your
life and that comes down to number one
which is actually figuring out your
priorities and i like to do this every
quarter i like to really evaluate the
priorities every quarter because every
quarter they change and so i know i just
talked about multitasking for me this
really is the antidote to multitasking
this is actually figuring out your
priorities and being totally focused and
bought in during that time and so first
we're going to list our priorities and
these are things in your life that
really matter what are you going to be
spending your time on so i think every
single quarter you should list out your
top five priorities for that quarter so
over the next three months what does
that look like for you what is a
priority and i can let you know for me
since my kids are quote unquote out of
school or homeschool family so for us
that's a very fluid statement but for
right now uh we are prioritizing family
time we're doing more trips we're doing
more things on the weekends we're
spending more time with our family
because of the season that we're in the
second priority is think media that's a
huge priority um as we're growing this
company as we're bringing people on and
hiring as we're expanding into new areas
uh growing this podcast and so many
different things it is a priority for me
right now the third one is definitely
ministry you know my husband and i we
love to open up our home to people and
to be able to uh be there in a in a real
spiritual way for people and so we want
to devote time to that and resources to
that so i want you to actually list out
what your priorities are what are the
priorities for you in this season
because once we know what those
priorities are we can then put them into
the calendar we can be calendar blocking
them which is the antidote to
multitasking right when you know what
you should be working on you should be
totally focused in that area but i want
to really take a look at when something
is a priority and is youtube a priority
is a question i want to ask you when you
were thinking about this season when
you're thinking about the next three
months when you're thinking about the
next year is youtube actually a priority
and you may be running a business right
now maybe you're a real estate agent or
a health coach or um you are uh helping
people in finances whatever that looks
like i want you to break it down even
more is youtube a priority because if
you're going to jump into doing youtube
as part of your marketing strategy if
you're going to be growing a business or
a brand with youtube then it needs to be
a priority in what you're doing because
a lot goes into making your channel
successful so is it actually a priority
and you know over the last uh six months
i don't know if you've noticed but i've
lost 20 pounds i mean that's only for
the people that are watching this but um
over the last six months my husband and
i have really been committed to our
health we've really been on a journey of
just you know uh we definitely got the
um uh we gained the weight during the
lockdown if you know what i mean so we
were in a season where we wanted to make
our health a priority and you know it
wasn't what we did um it wasn't like
okay it's a priority and then everything
changed
no we had to actually start working
towards that goal we had to start
working towards making that a priority
in our life the foods we were choosing
the activities we were doing
those types of things became a priority
in our life and over the last six months
my husband's actually lost 40 pounds
i've lost 20 pounds and it's been such
an incredible experience but the reason
that that happened the reason that we
got to this end goal was because we made
our health a priority so i want to ask
you is youtube an actual priority in
your life are you committed to doing the
things you need to do to make youtube
great and taking this back to even my
own experience over the last six months
i was committed to getting good sleep
because part of actually being able to
lose weight is that getting good sleep i
was committed to eating the right foods
i was committed to making sure i was
walking every day or lifting weights
every day i was committed to not
drinking and really cleaning out my
system so that i could be more healthy
and the same thing applies when you make
youtube a priority when you make youtube
a priority are you you're then scripting
out your videos when you make youtube a
priority you're sitting down to film two
videos when you make youtube a priority
you're spending time researching and
learning about youtube uh with us here
at think media and deeper into our
courses when you make a something a
priority in your life and you've listed
it out you then start to focus on making
that action happen and i do believe that
you should be setting really big goals
when you make something a priority like
i'm gonna make my family a priority and
we're gonna make sure we eat dinner four
times a week when you start making those
goals when you have something as listed
as the priority that you're going to
spend your time and attention and focus
on that actually becomes easier to
accomplish because you've already named
it you've already known that that's what
it is for you
so number one you need to make it a
priority i'm gonna get to uh the actual
way to break down those 300 minutes but
i've got two more um things we need to
go through before we even get to that
and the second thing is you need to
really evaluate the season of life that
you're in now when you look at the
season of life that you're in when
you're making things priorities you
really do need to evaluate this are you
in a season right now where you do have
five kids at home and so making youtube
as the number one priority probably
isn't going to happen are you in a
season of life right now where you know
the number one thing you need to be
doing is getting on the phones with
clients so that you can just be locking
in sales so you really need to evaluate
the season of life that you're in and
just take a step back and like really
evaluate it as you're looking at your
priorities yes family is a priority yes
work is a priority yes growing my
youtube channel is a priority
but when i take a look at the season of
life that i'm in that's going to
determine how much time i can spend in
each one of those priority buckets so
for right now where i'm at i'm spending
a lot of time in the growing of the
think media bucket that's a huge
priority for what is in my life right
now another big priority like i said are
my kids realizing that my son is going
to be out of the house in three years my
daughter's gonna be out of the house in
four years my other son i still have
eight to go but just understanding that
that limited time four more summers is
all i have with my daughter in the home
with us it makes me really look at that
priority different than when she was two
years old right so looking at the season
of life that i'm in i'm gonna determine
how much time i'm spending in each one
of those buckets and i want you to
evaluate that maybe you're driving right
now and you're just kind of thinking
about what the summer plans are and
you're just going week to week i want
you to really think about you know what
is the season of life i'm in where am i
right now like what are my priorities
where am i going how much time can i
spend in these different areas which is
why i created the five hour youtube work
week because i understand that trying to
fit in something else into your life can
be difficult when you already have so
much that you're juggling so as you're
making youtube a priority we're gonna
really figure out where those five hours
are coming from
and then lastly before we get into how
you spend those 300 minutes
i want you to remember that we really
are constricted to 24 hours in a day
there's only 24 hours that we get to use
and and i think that the way that we use
them wisely is really prioritizing our
dreams our goals our priorities over
other people's now i don't mean this in
like the selfish way that you should not
be giving time uh and resources to um to
the people around you i just mean that
if you're anything like me that one of
the hardest parts about putting your
dreams and goals first is that you're a
people pleaser and this is something
that i'm still working through even as a
37 year old woman i still want people
when they ask me if i can do something i
want to say yes i don't want to
disappoint them but if you're going to
list your priorities figure out the
season of life you're in know how much
time you could be spending in each one
of these areas then the next thing you
have to get really good at is saying no
and i found over coaching hundreds of
different content creators and
entrepreneurs that a lot of us have this
similarity that we really do want to
make people proud of us and we really do
want to
help people out but a lot of times when
we do that those things are the things
that are getting in the way of you doing
what you're called to do doing those
other things for other people i don't
think you should always say no but when
you really evaluate should you be on the
pta do when you really evaluate should
you be running that ministry when you
really evaluate should you be the person
that said yes to taking the other kids
in the neighborhood to soccer three days
a week is that actually what you should
be doing and so i've put together a
couple ways um that have helped me in
learning to say no because before you
can find those five hours we're probably
gonna have to say no to some things
because we are constricted to 24 hours
in a day so a couple ways that i've
learned to say no is just actually just
saying no thank you someone gives you uh
something that they would like you to be
a part of hey can you uh can you get on
the phone i'd like to pick your brain
right that happens to me a lot or
through instagram dms hey i've got a
question for you do you have any time
for me
it's not that i don't want to do those
things i just know that if i prioritize
every single ask that's coming in right
now i'm not going to be able to do the
actual priorities that i have already
laid out so just saying no no thank you
that sounds lovely or you know what i so
appreciate that offer maybe someone asks
you if you can run something or do
something or wants to be a part of
something you know what i really
appreciate that offer but it doesn't
actually fit in with my current
commitments that's one of the things i
say uh the next one is i'm not actually
able to make time for that right now um
this is something that my husband and i
both had to really evaluate in the last
season that we were in we were asked to
lead something and after prayer and
consideration and really looking through
what our priorities were we had to say
like i'm so sorry we actually don't have
time for that right now but think of us
in the future because every three months
we're reevaluating what our priorities
are
the last one is um thank you so much for
thinking of me but right now i'm at my
limit for outside commitments and i say
this actually a lot now um when i first
got started in youtube coaching i said
yes to every single person that asked me
if i could coach them and i wasn't even
charging what i should have been
charging and so i was spending a lot of
time doing a lot of free coaching i was
spending a lot of time hey can you look
at this thing hey can you maybe just
tell me what you would do here and i was
giving a lot of that outside time and
now through understanding that i have
certain priorities and i have certain
amount of time i can say yes to things
once i'm booked i'm booked i actually
don't open up my time slots for more and
i actually increase my prices as i'm
booking because i know that my time is
valuable and i want to make sure that
i'm spending it in the right places so
that could be just a couple ways
that you could do that so let's just
recap real quick and then i'll get into
the five hour youtube work week and how
you could be spending your time number
one you got to list your priorities
number two you have to identify what
season of life that you're in and number
three you have to learn how to say no
all right well let's jump into actually
how you can be creating a five-hour
youtube work week now this is if you are
trying to grow your youtube channel and
you are posting one video a week on your
channel how can you actually be spending
your time wisely every single week to be
working on moving your channel forward
um if you are watching this video right
now uh i'm gonna have right now being on
the screen uh this is what the five hour
youtube work week looks like and if
you're listening while you're driving
doing the dishes walking the dog
exercising good for you for exercising
i'm gonna just walk through and explain
this to you so number one uh you'd spend
60 minutes on researching your video
topics your content
and creating your outlines for your
scripts now i'll list videos down below
if you are watching on youtube and i'll
put them in the show notes below of
different videos we have of how to make
your scripts how to research for the
right videos what are the right videos
you should be making so you'd spend 60
minutes in your week doing that then you
would spend 90 minutes filming your
videos this includes setting up your
space testing your shot and actually
hitting record and that might have
shocked you there you might have thought
an hour and a half heather that's not
enough time well i want to encourage you
to try and trim the fat which means that
you might need to be practicing your
script in the mirror two nights before
so that you sit down in front of your
camera and you're delivering better
content it might mean that rather than
making one 35 minute video you're going
to make three 10-minute videos or one
10-minute video right i think a lot of
times content creators try and squeeze
everything into one video and not
realizing that you're here to make a
library of content so 90 minutes for
your filming then you'll spend 60
minutes in the editing process now you
might again said alert alert heather 60
minutes to edit it takes me seven hours
i'm just encouraging you that if you
only had five hours what would you spend
it doing and i don't want you to be
spending more than 60 minutes editing
your video now here's what i do want you
to learn how to do
eventually i want you to outsource this
eventually i want you to have a template
for this eventually you're understanding
that this isn't just you doing it solo
but that you need to build a team around
you to make these things happen
eventually i hope that other areas uh
that you're saying no to you can give
more time to your youtube channel and
development but for right now as we're
walking through five hour youtube work
week you want to spend 60 minutes
editing and
we have a ton of tutorials on think
media that'll help you walk through
editing software if i'm editing a video
i'm using simple things like my phone
i'm using my ipad i'm using imovie i'm
doing it very simple now here at think
media we have full-time editors because
we're making 10 12 videos a week you
don't need that we're doing the 5 hour
youtube work week so 60 minutes for your
editing then i want you to take 30
minutes to create your thumbnails for
your new video and you can use a
template that we have
here at think media we walk you through
how to create a thumbnail in two minutes
or less so you can find that video and
other videos about how to easily create
thumbnails
using simple software like canva and
those tutorials will be linked down
below as well as in the show notes for
you so only 30 minutes is all you need
to make that happen and then 30 minutes
for uploading your video you want to
make sure you're writing the description
putting the tags in making sure your
title's right and just making it look
great before you actually hit that
publish button the last 30 minutes of
those 300 minutes that i want you to use
wisely on your youtube channel is to
share out your video respond to the
comments send an email to your email
list whatever that looks like to be
marketing your video that's what you
would spend those last 30 minutes on so
that's the breakdown of the actual five
hour youtube work week if you're
listening to this podcast right now i
will make sure that you get the link to
this down in the show notes as well so
that you can go over to the youtube
channel subscribe and also uh see this
video so you can see the image of the
five hour youtube work week but that's
it that's what i want you to spend your
time doing if you are in the season
where you have five hours to devote to
your youtube channel this is part one of
a two-part series of productivity and
how you can actually get more done in
less time when you know how to do it
the productive way as a content creator
i want to say thank you for everyone who
has liked and subscribed over on itunes
thank you for being a part of our
community actually it's not itunes it's
actually on apple podcast so thank you
for liking and subscribing over on apple
podcast and today i want to shout out
athena athena wrote to us and said this
podcast will turn you into a youtuber by
following the tips shared in this
podcast i have improved my skills and
have grown my youtube channel six times
faster than ever before so thank you
athena for sending us and rating and
reviewing the show it means the world to
me to be able to get to read your
reviews and uh and get to see the
successes that you're having from being
a part of the think media community
thank you so much for being a part of
what we're doing here at think media and
i'll catch you in the next episode bye
[Music]
you